ow well many struggle with body image
and the goal of either losing or gaining
weight but it can be a lot tougher for
kids 8 news now reporter Mary Jane
beliesa shares how you can help your
teen with a positive body image
social media is only an Arms Reach away
with pictures and videos of how to
improve your appearance weight and style
Hannah Olivas has five kids she saw the
influential impact of social media even
more during the pandemic I think it
definitely affected kids because they
lost that Personal Touch seeing people
you know on the day-to-day basis there's
so many stigmas going around about how
we should look Mandy Baron is a licensed
psychotherapist and CEO of Mariah
Behavioral Health he focuses on teen
mental health treatment body positivity
is about accepting yourself for where
you are
understanding where you want to go
maintaining proper you know maintaining
good eating habits maintaining a love
for yourself recognizing that bodies can
be beautiful in all sizes he's seen an
uptick in anxiety and depression among
teens in Nevada in our eating disorder
program over the past 45 days we have
more requests for boys and for girls and
statistically speaking that is actually
the case Baron says being proactive and
having these conversations starts at
home dealing with teens is a two-fold
approach parents and kids and takes both
and from parent side like you said it
takes a village parents should not try
to operate alone know that you can get
help know their resources that's why
Olivas says she sets boundaries for her
family from what they eat to screen time
and making sure they get outside there
is an understanding that we can teach
them the importance of healthy and not
just the beauty the Aesthetics because
if if that's not internal then they're
struggling
now Baron says while eating disorders
have become a prevalent issue in our
state right now Nevada does not have a
license type for the treatment so he's
working with the state to try and change
that by defining what an eating disorder
is and supporting the proper legislation